ein britischer physiker warnt vor einer
echten katastrophe für die erde
verursacht durch die digitale revolution
social media checken filme stream fotos
in die cloud laden und beim einkaufen
bargeldlos bezahlen obwohl die digitale
revolution gerade erst begonnen hat
bringt sie nicht nur vorteile mit sich
denn die stetig wachsende
informationstechnologie verbraucht
enorme ressourcen
das könnte in einer katastrophe enden
klicks hans in future hier gibt es drei
mal pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
als hätte die welt derzeit nicht mit
genügend katastrophen klarzukommen
klimawandel und das corona virus um nur
mal zwei stichworte zu nennen der
britische physiker melvin wachsen warnt
jetzt vor einer ganz anderen bedrohung
in seiner aktuellen studie
prognostiziert er eine sogenannte
information katastrophe damit meint der
forscher aldi folgen die die wachsende
und zunehmende digitalisierung mit sich
bringen wird denn wer glaubt dass wir
mit dem internet und der modernen
kommunikation ausschließlich auf einem
ökologischen und nachhaltigen weg sind
der irrt sich ein wenig dazu ein paar
beispiele eine suchanfrage von google
verbraucht etwa 0,3 watt stunden heißt
also im klartext mit der energie die man
für 20 suchanfragen im internet benötigt
könnte man eine energiesparlampe eine
ganze stunde lang brennen lassen auch
wenn man das schnell vergisst ist das
internet an sich keine wolke irgendwo
weit weg stattdessen stecken hinter
alldem riesige rechenzentren in
deutschland konzentriert sich der
großteil solcher rechenzentren auf die
stadt frankfurt die server hier
verbrauchen 20 prozent der städtischen
energie also mehr als der gesamte
frankfurter flughafen in ganz
deutschland verbraucht die gesamte netz
infrastruktur etwa 55 terawattstunden
für die digitale welt hierzulande
braucht es also umgerechnet 10 mittlere
kraftwerke die strom erzeugen das netz
ist also physisch und real und die menge
der daten die gespeichert werden muss
nimmt immer weiter zu
der physiker marvin wachsen beschreibt
die informations katastrophe als ein
phänomen das klein anfängt und
exponentiell wächst dabei beruft er sich
auf zahlen und daten von big data
forschungseinrichtungen und ibm dazu der
wissenschaftler
das wachstum der digitalen information
scheint unaufhaltsam 90 prozent der
heute existierenden daten sind erst in
den letzten zehn jahren entstanden und
dieser trend scheint nicht zu stoppen
der festplattenhersteller seagate geht
davon aus dass die globale datenmenge
von 33 zeitarbeit vor zwei jahren 2018
bis zum jahr 2025 um das fünffache
ansteigen wird in fünf jahren werden wir
demnach also bei 175 c gespeichert auf
blu ray discs würde dieser stapel also
eng zusammen gelegt an datenmenge 23 mal
bis zum mond reichen
das fachgebiet von mailboxen ist die
physik und so veranschaulicht er den
zukünftigen trend auf eine ganz neue art
und weise eine der zentralen
forschungsfragen denen er nachging
lautet also wann genau wird es mehr bits
an digitalen informationen geben als
atome in unserem planeten seiner
berechnung zufolge ist das ein
überschaubarer zeitraum bei der analyse
gingen davon aus dass die digitale daten
produktion pro jahr um 20 prozent
zunimmt bereits in 350 jahren könnte es
demnach also bereits mehr biss als
irdische atome geben wenn die digitale
daten produktion jährlich sogar noch
stärker zunehmen würde beispielsweise um
50 prozent wäre es sogar bereits im jahr
2170 soweit in 150 jahren also kurz zum
besseren verständnis die wissenschafts
community schätzt die zahl der atome in
unserem planeten auch von 10 hoch 50
eine wirklich unvorstellbar hohe zahl
also fest steht künftige fortschritte in
diesem bereich könnten boxen zufolge für
die menschheit tragische konsequenzen
haben der physiker nennt dazu drei
gründe zum einen sieht er die
speicherung der gigantischen datenmengen
im realen raum als problematisch dazu
schreibt er in seiner aktuellen studie
selbst wenn man annimmt dass künftige
technische fortschritte die größe eines
bits bis auf fast atom größe verringern
würde dieses volumen an digitaler
informationen mehr platz einnehmen als
unser ganzer planet das wäre das was wir
als informations katastrophe definieren
denn digitale informationen haben in
gewisser art und weise auch eine masse
das muss genau erklärt werden und manche
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
berufen sich dabei auf albert einsteins
formeln gleich ma c quadrat dazu melvin
wachsen nach dieser erweiterung ist
informationen ein physikalischer zustand
der je nach umständen in masse oder
energie umgewandelt werden kann
schon der legendäre physiker archibald
wheeler betrachtete das universum als
aus drei komponenten besteht teilchen
feldern und informationen er prägte
dafür die phrase it from bit es lohnt
sich wirklich da ein bisschen genauer
hinzuschauen denn john archibald wheeler
war wohl wirklich einer der kreativsten
physiker des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
konkret bezeichnet er ein physikalisches
system als it beispielsweise wäre also
an teilchen er namen bestimmten zustand
ein it die informationen in dieser
zustand funktion ist wieder zufolge ein
bit forscherinnen und forscher messen
demnach also bestimmte größen und kommen
mit hilfe dieser messung also darauf
dass zeichen sich in einem bestimmten
zustand befinden ist ein elektrischer
puls ein lichtpunkt auf dem bildschirm
oder aber ein klick im detektor all das
können antworten des apparats sein und
das ganze stellte damals bereits die
physik auf den kopf denn diesem konzept
zufolge geht es in der welt ja gar nicht
mehr um die materiellen sondern um die
information allen elemente das
elementare system also ist letztlich
nichts anderes als der repräsentant
einer information zurück zum boxen er
setzt ein bit also gleich mit einer art
abstraktem teilchen ohne ladung und spin
doch dieses verfügt über eine masse und
genau die entspricht der notwendigen
energie um es überhaupt zu produzieren
und zu speichern so hat der physiker
sogar eine rechnung dazu aufgestellt
wieviel masse ein bit bei raumtemperatur
hätte natürlich ist es eine super
winzige masse doch wie so oft die menge
macht derzeit haben wir es mit der masse
zu tun die der masse eines winzigen
escherichia coli bakteriums entspricht
alle informationen also die derzeit auf
der erde existieren wegen dieser
rechnung zufolge gerade einmal rund 230
trillion street kilogramm doch das
könnte sich in der nahen zukunft ändern
und das nicht zu knapp wieder mal wie es
in so vielen unserer videos auch beim
klimawandel zum beispiel vorkommt oder
bei corona die exponentielle entwicklung
boxens studie zufolge
könnten wir bereits in 188 jahren bei
einem kilogramm an informations masse
angelangt sein
und zwar dann wenn die menge an
digitaler information pro jahr um etwa
20 prozent wächst ein kilogramm schön
und gut das könnte die erde ja wohl noch
gut wegstecken doch achtung denn bereits
nach knapp 500 jahren könnte die masse
der bits und bytes bereits der hälfte
der erdmasse entsprechen so boxens
analyse klar ist an dieser stelle auch
dass die vom boxen genannten
jahreszahlen so nicht in stein gemeißelt
sind sondern eher als ungefähre angaben
zu verstehen sind denn entscheidend
dafür ist ja wie sich die wachstumsraten
in zukunft tatsächlich entwickelt und
außerdem auch welche technischen
verbesserungen es in der zukunft geben
wird in seiner studie gehen wuchsen
dabei allerdings davon aus dass sowohl
die datenverarbeitung als auch die
speicherung maximal effizient gestaltet
sein werden den dritten punkt den boxen
als mögliche gefahr sieht der handelt
vom verbrauch der ressourcen konkret
geht es um den strombedarf der
informationstechnologie und der ist
wirklich enorm bereits jetzt geht ein
prozent der globalen stromproduktion an
die rechenzentren dieser welt und
achtung dahin enthalten ist nicht einmal
der strombedarf des mobilfunks der
netzwerktechnologie und der endgeräte
eine analyse aus dem vergangenen jahr
2019 zufolge nutzten mehr als vier
milliarden menschen weltweit das
internet und jeder von uns hinterlässt
einen digitalen fußabdruck was ich damit
meine
alle online aktivitäten wie
beispielsweise bargeld durch bezahlen
oder das nutzen von streaming-diensten
braucht energie und das ist noch längst
nicht in unseren köpfen angekommen
denn auf den ersten blick überwiegen die
vorteile der digitalisierung mit ihrer
hilfe kann die energiewende stattfinden
und viele dinge in der wirtschaft laufen
sparsamer ab als ohne sie doch auf der
anderen seite hat die digitalisierung
auch negative effekte vor allem in
sachen umweltschutz und nachhaltigkeit
und das fängt schon bei der herstellung
internetfähiger geräte an
dafür notwendig sind enorme mengen an
energie nicht zu vergessen dabei das
autonome fahren oder das internet der
dinge beides steht noch ganz am anfang
doch auch diese bereiche werden die
datenmengen exponentiell zunehmen lassen
dafür notwendig riesige rechenzentren
und das sind wieder wahre energiefresser
verantwortlich dafür vor allem die
klimaanlagen die notwendig sind um die
server auf etwa 25 grad zu temperieren
ökologisch gesehen sind außerdem auch
die co2 emissionen der information
telekommunikationstechnik der betrieb
des internets und der internetfähigen
geräte verursacht bereits jetzt so viele
emissionen wie der innerdeutsche
flugverkehr konkret handelt es sich um
etwa 33 millionen tonnen co2 emissionen
pro jahr
und auch hier ist die tendenz steigend
doch zurück zum strombedarf der
informationstechnologie genau hier sieht
mailbox sind die größte gefahr und
andere wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftler geben ihm dabei recht
der aktuellen studie zufolge könnten wir
hier bereits sehr zeitnah an eine
planetare grenzen kommen auch bei dieser
berechnung geht der physiker von einem
digitalen wachstum von etwa 20 prozent
pro jahr aus und so könnte die
informationstechnologie bereits in 285
jahren die gesamte stromproduktion der
heutigen erde benötigen zusammengefasst
waren der forscher also davor dass die
digitale informationstechnologie
planetare grenzen sprengt und das in
dreierlei hinsicht
er führt dazu den energiebedarf die
masse und den nötigen platz aller bits
und bytes auf dazu das fazit von
mailboxen wir sind dabei unseren
planeten bit für bit zu verändern und
das kann zu einer unsichtbaren krise
führen wie realistisch seine prognosen
wirklich sind und steuern wir
tatsächlich gerade auf eine information
katastrophe sowie von boxen befürchtet
zu solche extrapolation also die
bestimmung eines mathematischen
verhaltens über den gesicherten bereich
hinaus gab es auch schon in der
vergangenheit und in vielen fällen
trafen die erwarteten ergebnisse nicht
ein beispielsweise sagten die beiden
biologen paul und anne ehrlich im jahr
1068 voraus dass das schlimme
hungersnöte geben wird war die erde die
schnell wachsende bevölkerung in zukunft
nicht ernähren können
doch heute ist klar dass die
geburtenrate in vielen regionen dieser
erde sinkt zudem können heutzutage viel
mehr menschen satt werden wenn die
nahrung nur besser verteilt würde zurück
zur information katastrophe die der
physiker mailboxen für die zukunft
voraussagt für viele experten experten
steht außer frage dass der energiebedarf
der informations technologie zunimmt
wird der schwedische it experte anders
andré hatte bereits vor fünf jahren die
prognose aufgestellt dass der
energiebedarf der informations
technologie im jahr 2030 die hälfte der
weltweiten stromerzeugung verschlingen
wird und es gab weitere analysen die
einen ähnlichen trend prognostizierten
doch es gibt auch fachleute die diesen
prognosen mit skepsis gegenüberstehen so
auch der us-wissenschaftler ms
im renommierten fachmagazin nature es
gab viele alarmierende vorhersagen zum
steigenden energiebedarf der
informations technologie in kommenden
jahren
sie erwiesen sich alle als unsinn in den
vergangenen jahren nämlich haben
verbesserte technologien und
organisationen den strombedarf konstant
gehalten und das obwohl die aufgaben
größer wurden oder home working über das
internet führt zu weniger energiebedarf
im verkehr natürlich heißt das nicht
dass das auch in den kommenden jahren
genauso sein wird dennoch ist die studie
von boxen wichtig um zu verdeutlichen
dass die digitale revolution nicht nur
vorteile mit sich bringt stattdessen ist
sie von nachhaltigkeit und umweltschutz
er entfernt denn die moderne
kommunikation und das internet sind
echte energiefresser inwieweit die
digitale information in der zukunft
wirklich wächst hängt entscheidend davon
ab wie sich die bevölkerungszahlen
entwickeln werden und zudem auch
inwieweit auch in ärmeren ländern der
zugang zu solchen neuen technologie
möglich wird diesen punkt merkt
mailboxen auch selbst in seiner studie
an wie umweltschädlich sind netflix
youtube und so weiter da erfahrt ihr
mehr also hier in diesem video über den
energiebedarf von video-streaming ist es
wirklich so schädlich cedric von doktor
watson hat das mal genau nachgerechnet
also anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran